[Music]
hi there
i'm john creative director here at this
human house thank you for tuning in to
appropriating nature part 2
home edition created in partnership with
design singapore
and the national design center as a
botanical design studio we have the
privilege of working with the most
amazing flowers
foliage plants and produce every single
day this has been a source of great joy
for us
and the reason why we do what we do now
every member of my team
enjoys an emotional connection with
nature they continue to deepen as we
discover new things to be thrilled and
delighted by
the light comes to us in many forms for
me the discovery of an orchid i've never
seen before
or it could be the color of the veins of
the leaf the texture of bark
or many a time simply witnessing the
savage beauty
of nature's wildness we've created this
series to encourage you along in
developing your relationship with the
natural world
so you know for yourself how truly
special nature is
and hopefully what is special to you is
also worth protecting
in this series my colleagues and i will
demonstrate and share some of the ways
in which we bring nature into ours and
our clients homes
and spaces one of the things that
thrills us the most
is when we get dms of creations you have
made inspired by our work
we couldn't be happier to know that what
we do has an effect beyond ourselves
we feel seen we hope you'll be inspired
to make something at home
and look forward to seeing your
creations in our giveaway you will find
full details on how to participate
in the following video captions at home
edition
[Laughter]
what is wrong with us in this segment
i'm going to be working with foliage
i'm intentionally keeping this simple
just one type of foliage for each
arrangement
and the point of paring it down is to
keep the focus on the beauty of the
material in and of itself
today i'm gonna be working with some
bamboo and this was cut for us by our
contractors
you're gonna find bamboo everywhere in
singapore and if you're lucky
a neighbor might have to trim their
bamboo down
or you might find it outside of a road
okay so
this this is some pretty ginormous uh
stems of bamboo and what you're gonna
need is a shears
a good pair of shears and and a saw
so i'm gonna have to cut this down um
[Music]
okay this is every day at work
so i've weighted down this vessel with
some concrete blocks
when the bamboo gets really high you do
need that stability
and for the purposes of this
demonstration i'm just going to imagine
that the height of the ceiling is where
the roll of paper ends and you would
imagine
that i might want to keep my branches
shorter than
the height of the ceiling but this may
not be the case sometimes it's nice that
the top of the branches graze the
ceiling
and what this does it emphasizes the
length of the branches and that the
arrangement
cannot actually be contained within the
space this gives a drama
using some of the shorter secondary
branches to create
a bit of a nest inside the opening of
this vessel is very large
and so what sometimes what's helpful is
if there's a network of
branches in there to help support the
stem so
you'll notice obviously that i'm not
there's no water in this vessel and
that's because
this is a fresh cut arrangement cut stem
arrangement that
will continue to dry well in this space
it will
retain a bit of its greenness because
it's not been bleached by the sun but
bamboo that's
been bleached by the sun it actually
turns a lovely shade of gold
as i'm composing sometimes because the
bamboo is fairly
thin i'm actually doubling up the stem
to give it more
visual impact
so even within this arrangement i'm
trying to
develop densities of foliage uh to give
it more dimension
it's just like shading and so i'm trying
to add this to the left side of the
arrangement
to create kind of a darker spot and
create a kind of focus
to this haze
so what i'm doing here is bundling the
shorter stems of bamboo
and the beauty of a dry arrangement
because you don't need a water source
and the kind of friction created by this
network of stems
i'm able to shove it inside and kind of
just disappears
so even within a mono ingredient
arrangement
what i'm trying to do is create movement
and shape and because these
bamboo branches so flexible um i'm
actually just kind of like
weaving them to create this movement
through or like almost like a ribbon
i'm realizing now as i'm making that
this side is looking
a little bit more interesting so i'm
going to be rotating
this vessel a little more to that side
and i think i think that
is possibly a better orientation for it
so i'm trimming
the strands uh near the base so that
the vessel becomes more prominent
so people always think of arranging as
an additive process but
it's actually quite non-linear it's
additive and subtractive
i'm not liking how the stem is looking
here i'm going to trim that down
a little further so the cut stem is not
so
so visible and after that full body
workout i just have a break
we have this beautiful barnacle vessel
here and it's got these uh
jug handles it recalls a more classical
type of shape and we're just gonna use
one palm leaf for this
and the idea is that it acts as a
counterpoint
to the chaotic lines of all this bamboo
here the geometry
of each palm leaf is just so spectacular
this is actually a baby bismarck beef
and it's got this silver screen quality
to it and it's actually a coating
of glaucus which gives it that silvery
appearance sometimes all you need is
just to
show it off singularly people tend to
think of
foliage as just leaves well these are
leaves as well
just in a shape and form that is a
little bit more in common
i'm going to arrange it completely erect
just as is because i think it showcases
its individual quality the best way
sensitive era
lasts a long time cut out of water but
what you might realize
is that they tend to root after a while
so
this arrangement might actually last
more than a couple months it might
actually grow into it
eventually um i really like that the
straightness of this enzyme
emphasizes the bulbous quality the
bottom of this vessel
it almost looks like a big bum the whole
point of this exercise with one
ingredient
for each arrangement is to bring
emphasis to the beauty of each type of
foliage
and its vessel the vessel honors the
material and the material honors the
vessel
simple it's not all the simplistic or
easy as you can see
thank you for joining me today
hi i'm carol from this unit house and
i'm really excited about all these
ingredients that we've gathered for you
today
this morning i was at the wet market and
found some really cool stuff
we've got long beans baby mangoes as
well as bamboo shoots now these
ingredients are not uncommon but if you
were to think about it
each of them have very interesting
characteristics that i would like to
bring to the table
long beans are almost always cut up in
dishes and here i really want to
emphasize
the length of them even thinking about
braiding them just as i would with my
hair
and sing purines is such a practical
bunch of people the question that i'm
asked most when i use
any fruits or vegetable in my
arrangement is can i eat it
the assumption here is that if you do
not consume it as food it's wasteful
but i want to promote the idea that
aesthetic consumption
or eating with your eyes is just as
valid
so that's why i selected these unripe
baby mangoes for its cuteness
now i also wanted to include flowers in
my arrangement and was very lucky to
have
received these vibrant creep muscles
that was harvested from our garden
this morning and the minute i saw them i
knew that i wanted to pair with these
tangy mango excerpts and because we
already have
such a contrasting color between the
mango and the violet i wanted the rest
of the colors in the flowers to be a bit
more subdued
this fritillaria whose petals look like
mini grapes
and these beautiful garlic scapes
are primarily green but i've selected
them
also because it has this beautiful tinge
of purple in it
which i find would be so complimentary
against the other flowers that i've
chosen now
first things first i'm going to refer to
the objects in front of me
as vessels and not vases because
people tend to associate vases with a
particular shape
when in fact i'm going to be showing you
that we can make
arrangements in any kind of receptacle
that holds water which is exactly what a
vessel is
here's a ceramic trough you may have
already
something similar to this at home like a
football
or a shell dish this is what i would
call
a taper vessel because its mouth is
narrower than its body
and it's extremely helpful when you
don't have a lot of materials to work
with
because it's just less that you can fit
in there now this
is my favorite vessel if you discount
its ears
the shape of the vessel is really
similar to that of a cut or a cylinder
which is a very common shape of vessel
um this is my quirky wild card vessel
it's got tree spouts i don't know if i'm
going to use every spout
but i'm throwing it in just because i
think it's special
what i'm trying to do today is to create
a multi-part arrangement
these vessels are basically stand-ins
for where i want my material to be
in space i'm going to make sure that all
my vessels have water in them
every vessel is different but as a
ballpark i like to have my vessels
between half to three quarters full
you can always chop them up later so i'm
going to start with preet myrtle because
this is my feature ingredient
and i'm going to use this to flesh out
the overall shape of my arrangement
in this trough there are two metal pin
frogs or kansans
which will help hold the branches in
place
if you're looking to buy one of these i
encourage you to buy the heavier ones
which are better for branches we also
apply floral putty
to the base of these kenzans so that
they don't slip around
all these are available at your flora
wholesalers
so i want to go big with the creep model
but i don't want it to
look too heavy as well so i'm just being
mindful with that as i'm making
creep metal stems are pretty thick and
so i find that splitting the ends of the
stems
makes it easier to penetrate the kanzan
i'm trying to create density in parts of
this arrangement
to help lead your eye through the piece
sometimes i want
my branch to go super horizontal and
it's almost impossible to pierce it into
the kanzan
so what then i do is i would use a cable
tie and attach it to a bunch that has
already been pierced in
i'm really enjoying how it's shaving out
to look it's light it's airy
it's giving me the feeling of springtime
which is the whole point of using
flowering branches like cream muscle
with this fertilaria
the opportunity to create even more flow
and movement
because these flowers are so gestural
this frustularia comes to us from
holland
and as much as we love using locally and
regionally sourced materials
sometimes there are qualities so
specific to a flower
that it cannot be replaced and we don't
want to be dogmatic about our practice
i might consider using tuber rolls but
it just doesn't have the same curvature
so what i'm trying to do with this
fritillaria is i'm trying to
weave this band of green through
the piece because i don't like my
arrangements to look overly stylized
although i'm weaving the fritillaria
through the arrangement
you'll notice that i'm not doing it in
just one direction
i have materials coming forwards and
then to the left and to the right side
i'm basically just securing this with
green tape which is
a thinner form of duct tape
[Music]
i think it's super cute that this vessel
has ears
and it's like i'm creating this turban
of braids on top of it
i thought that this would be a fun way
of emphasizing the characteristics of
these vessels
now i've decided that i will create a
focal point with these garlic scapes
their heads have a very solid shape that
when clustered
will draw the eye too as i mentioned
this vessel has a very narrow neck and
i'm almost running out of space
because garlic scapes don't need a water
sauce
i'm actually just going to put the stems
outside of it and be okay
i'm also going to try to make sure that
the garlic skins point in different
directions and
not all of them are pointing to the same
way i'm thinking about them almost like
little birds in the nest
when i'm arranging i feel like i'm
telling a story
and i'm leaving these little clues and
surprises for people to discover
so i have these garlic scapes nestled
deep within the arrangement
to create some depth generally i like to
progress with my materials
systematically from one to another as
i'm building up the arrangement this
sequence really helps me to organize my
thoughts
and it's a much cleaner way of layering
and having control over the process
xor i like hydrangeas in that they are
quite round in shape but
they're a little area i can break that
roundness by smashing
them together essentially trying to
create clouds
this pink banana has a rocket-like shape
and i think it's going to be
so cute for it to emerge from the head
of this vessel
so a way of having the fruit high is
just to skew with them
and now for the final flourish a baby
mangoes casually on the table
just like i fell from the sky
and i think i'm done
[Music]
you